Today we'll be speaking with Dr. James
Gross from Stanford University on emotion
regulation.
Dr. James Gross is a professor of
psychology at Stanford University.
He received his BA in philosophy and
psychology from Yale University and phd in
clinical psychology from UC Berkeley with
subsequent postdoctoral training at Uc
San Francisco.
Dr. Gross is widely regarded as the
pioneer in the field of emotion regulation
and his work has received numerous
awards including early career awards,
um,
from the society for psychophysiological
research in early career award from the
American Psychological
Association Outstanding Young
Researcher Award from the
Western Psychological Association and
countless teaching awards such as an award
for teaching excellence
at Stanford University,
such as the Walter j Gorgeous Award
for excellence in teaching the Bass
University fellow and undergraduate
education and a postdoctoral mentor new
award from Stanford University.
His work has been supported by
numerous grants from the NIH, NSF,
the Nid among others.
He's also published over 200 papers and
edited the authoritative handbook of
emotion regulation.
So I now turn to our experts in
emotion interview with Dr. James Gross.
So welcome James. Thank you for
speaking with us today. Pleasure.
I want it to begin with talking with
you about how you first got started in
studying emotion.
So could you tell us a bit about what
first sparked your interest in emotion
June?
That's a great question.
I've been interested in emotion for as
long as I can remember. Uh, academically,
the source of my interest comes from a
longstanding interest in philosophy where
at least in the western tradition,
there's this rich history of questions
around the role of reason versus passions
and guiding behavior.
And as I wrote philosophy paper
after philosophy paper at Yale as an
undergraduate,
I,
I found that the core of my interests
really revolved around problems,
about when reason should be
in control and when passions,
including emotions should be in control.
And that's what laid the foundation
for my work in psychology,
trying to understand empirically
how to balance the two.
Oh,
that's fascinating.
So you had this philosophical interest
in the nature of emotion that you're
later able to tackle with
empirical tools. Exactly. Right.
So speaking of empirical
tools is actually,
I have a few questions I'd like to
ask you about your research. Um,
so we can all relate to
emotion in our everyday lives,
but it seems like defining things like
emotion and emotion regulation are really
a thorny and tricky issue.
So as an expert in this field,
I was curious to hear how you think about
defining what emotion is and how it's
different from emotion regulation.
That's a great question.
Uh,
in everyday life I think there's a
very strong sense in which we make a
distinction between the emotions we have
and the things do to manage or change
those emotions.
And so in our work we find it useful
to map onto that intuitive or lay
distinction.
And what we have in mind is something
I think fairly straightforward in many
circumstances. Uh, an emotion might start,
we might start feeling angry with a
spouse or a child and as that anger and
folds coloring our thinking,
our facial behavior,
our physiologic responses,
as we become aware of that anger,
we may feel that that's
not the right response.
That's not a helpful response
in this circumstance.
And so try to modify or change
how that anger is playing out.
We may try not to show it or
may even try not to feel it.
And it's that late distinction between
the emotion on the one hand and efforts
to modify or change it that we're trying
to map onto when we make a distinction
between emotion reactions on the one
hand and emotion regulation on the other.
Another context for this distinction
that's important to us is uh,
how it plays out between people because
emotions aren't just things that happen
inside a person, but also
things that happen, uh, very
importantly between people.
So for example,
with a child or a spouse or a parent
that the other person may be in an
emotional state, let's say of sadness
where let's take the case of a child,
someone, uh, is very,
very disappointed and upset at
something that's happened at school.
And it's often the case,
particularly for young children,
they don't have the skills yet to
manage or modify their own emotions.
And so they may come to a parent or
older sibling for help and regulating
emotions.
And in that case too,
I think it makes sense to try to
distinguish between the emotions that are
playing out in the child
and the regulatory processes
that are invoked in the
key in this case with bio helping other.
And so I think what's important June
and thinking about this debate about
whether it makes sense to distinguish
between emotion reactions on the one hand
and emotion regulation on the other is
to ask for what purpose local purpose are
we making this distinction.
And I think part of the confusion in the
literature is that some people looking
at this distinction say,
well that's not a distinction
about real things in the world.
That is to say you can't guarantee with
necessary and sufficient conditions.
You can always distinguish between an
emotion generative process and an emotion
regulatory process. And my
response to that is that, uh,
I take more of a, um,
instrumental, uh, perspective and,
and think that this kind of distinction
isn't so much about defining natural
kinds in the world as it is about
creating contexts in which we can ask and
answer empirical questions
that matter to us.
And so this is a distinction
of convenience and I think
in some cases it's easy
to draw the line between
emotion generation and
regulation as in the cases I've
given.
But in other cases it becomes more blurry.
And that I feel from an instrumental
perspective it's not a problem because in
those cases we might not want to make
such a tight distinction between the two.
That that's great. And it relates to
what I was going to ask you more about,
which is you really laid out this roadmap
or process model of emotion regulation
that really has shaped the
way we all think about, um,
not only when emotion
regulation strategies occur,
but what specific kinds of strategies
or ways we use to manage our emotions.
And I was wondering,
when you think about sort of the future
of where emotion regulation is headed,
do you see this model changing or
growing over time? And in what ways?
June, uh, the process model of
emotion regulation is meant to be a,
a framework within which we all can think
about how emotions play out over time
and how they can then be modified
either by ourselves or by other people.
And I emphasize it's a framework
rather than a well developed model.
And the distinction for me rests on the
idea that this is just an initial sort
of draft of a workspace that will
absolutely evolve as we fill in with more
understanding and more knowledge.
And so for me,
the framework a really rests on a couple
of very basic assumptions that emotions
develop over time. They change over
time in a context sensitive fashion. Uh,
they may vary dramatically across
context and across people, but the,
as we see emotions play out
in ourselves and in others,
we can usefully draw attention to the
ways that we and others may try to change
that emotion trajectory.
And as you say,
I've tried to distinguish among five
families of regulatory processes ranging
from very early efforts to intervene,
to change the emotion.
It's playing out too much
later, uh, interventions.
And I think there's gonna be
lots of change in that space.
I think it's a very generous space.
Um,
they're really rests on these very basic
assumptions that I think there's every
reason to think well, have, um,
a utility as we move forward.
But there are loads of other questions.
I think that this kind of
model, um, requires that we ask,
for example,
we need to ask questions about how people
actually are trying to modify their
own emotions and others' emotions.
And we are only beginning to understand
how people go about regulating their
emotions, not just what they do, but,
but what their emotion
regulation goals are. And from a,
from a lay perspective,
you might think it's easy.
People try to turn down bad
emotions and turn up good emotions.
But what does that mean? It's
certainly not as simple as,
uh, always trying to, uh,
to do away with negative emotions once
it feel yucky or increase emotions that
feel good. There are many
instances, as you know,
very well from your work where we want
to turn down positive emotions and
perhaps turned up negative emotions.
So that's an example of the way that I
think this framework will need to grow as
people do more work on the processes
involved in emotion regulation.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And as you think of this sort of process
model or framework emerging and growing,
I do you see any certain
types of influential tools
or methodologies that are
going to be most critical
on these next steps?
No,
I think there's going to be a mix of um,
advances that are going to be
really important in this space. Um,
some of these are going to be theoretical
as we really try to better understand
the larger context within which
people are regulating their emotions.
I've said that in my own work we focused
on trying to draw some distinctions
among processes that people use
to modify the emotion trajectory.
But I've said that we need to broaden
our view to understand not just what
people are trying to do but
why they're trying to do it.
And I think we can learn quite
a bit from other related, uh,
research efforts to understand motivated
behavior more generally and goal
directed behavior more generally
asking in this case as in other cases,
not just what people are doing
and why they're doing it,
but how this plays in with all of the
other many goals that we have as we move
through life. And so part of the, uh, I
think effort will need to be theoretical.
So conceptual advances in our thinking,
um,
borrowing as we can from other,
uh, theoretical traditions.
I think another important growth point
for us will be not just theoretical but
empirical.
And here we're at a working in a really
exciting time where there as you know,
very well or range of new tools,
uh,
more sophisticated approaches
to behavior analysis,
more sophisticated approaches to tracking
people's subjective experience as it
evolves over time, but also neuro
biological assessment tools,
functional imaging techniques as well as,
uh,
procedures for a better understanding,
people with various types of brain
damage and in healthy individuals,
uh,
better understanding the
role of particular brain
systems through inactivation
procedures. Uh, uh, such as tms,
transcranial magnetic stimulation.
So I think there's a range of tools,
both conceptual and empirical that will
be brought to bear to help us better
understand how people manage
their emotions as they unfold.
And I know in your more recent work,
you've driven it in a direction
that's really interesting,
sort of relating emotion regulation
to clinical health, health outcomes,
and in particular focusing on
social anxiety disorder. Um,
what have you found when you think about
and research social anxiety disorder?
How do you characterize the nature of
emotion regulation and the ways that may
be going awry?
June? Uh, you know,
one of the strategies that we and
others have used is to try to understand
emotion processes by looking at
clinical contexts such as social anxiety
disorder. And, uh, one of the
surprises I think for us as,
um,
as been the case for other people who've
used effect of science approaches to
better understand clinical phenomena is
that everything isn't exactly as we had
expected it might be.
Um,
and I think that really is a testament
to the value of applying effect of
science measures. And, and
con, uh, conceptual, um, um,
sort of rubrics to these complex
clinical phenomena. For example,
just give you a quick example. Um,
in social anxiety disorder, uh,
people, uh, are often quite impaired,
unable to interact with others socially
unable to work as they'd like to,
uh, um, outside the home and, uh,
this can be really debilitating disorder.
And the core of the disorder in the
diagnostic and statistical manual is
heightened levels of anxiety.
And that led us to the, you know,
straightforward assumption that when
we carefully assessed people in the
laboratory using functional imaging,
that we'd be able to easily distinguish
between the emotional responses to have
people with social anxiety disorder on
the one hand and healthy matched controls
on the other in terms of the magnitude
of the emotional response in some of
these brain systems such as the Amygdala
insula that are thought to be important
to emotion generation. To our
surprise, what we're finding in these,
uh, laboratory contexts is that
when we build, uh, relevant,
um, socially rich, uh, stimuli,
and we show these to participants who
are either characterized as having social
anxiety or our match controls,
you don't have the disorder.
We see robust responses,
physiologic responses in both groups
that are often indistinguishable.
Now that's not to say that subjectively
people with social anxiety aren't
suffering and reporting
very high levels of anxiety.
But when you look at some of the core
brain systems that are thought to subserve
emotional responding, we see
often no differences, uh,
in,
uh,
these brain systems
response in these contexts.
And this is in context after context.
Um,
and what that tells me is that our
conceptions of emotion reactivity as being
simply greater and social anxiety
across the board as compared to healthy
controls or too simple that there's
a response fractionation such that
subjectively,
in certainly there are parts of the
brain other than these core brain systems
that are thought to be important to
emotion generation that must reflect this
difference.
But the simple assumption that there's
obvious and gigantic reactivity
differences is too simple.
Misses the mark.
I think another surprise for us is related
to the notion that people with social
anxiety have much greater
reactivity is the idea that they uh,
cannot use appropriate
regulation strategies.
That the reason that they have greater
reactivity is that they simply can't use
a healthy strategies like reappraisal,
which involves thinking differently
about upsetting situations.
And what we found in our
laboratory studies is that
when appropriately cute and
instructed people with social anxiety
disorder are just about as good at using
reappraisal as healthy controls and that
now again as a bit of a surprise and
suggests that not that there's nothing
to learn here but that we've been focused
in the wrong place rather than assuming
greater reactivity rather than assuming
failures across the board.
In regulation,
what we think is happening is that
people are unable when not queued.
So in the real world they're unable to,
if they have social anxiety,
appropriately invoke skills
that they actually have.
And that then points I
think to a great mystery,
which is why aren't they
using the skills they have?
And that would be an example of the kind
of thing we're learning in this work.
Yeah. And when we think about this work,
you know, beyond social anxiety disorder,
it sounds like there's lessons we could
apply to a host of different disorders,
depression, bipolar disorder, et Cetera.
Do you feel like there's big picture
lessons to take away about emotion
regulation and psychopathology?
Absolutely. Chan. I think that um, the,
the work that we and others are doing
on specific disorders such as social
anxiety disorder, major depressive
disorder, bipolar disorder,
borderline personality disorder,
borderline personality disorder, um, uh,
all,
all of these research programs I think
are only partly about the specific
disorders. And I'm actually much more
interested in the general lessons,
which I think are,
are many that we really need to be careful
with our assumptions that a clinical
traditions and even diagnostic criteria
may not rich to be richly informative
about underlying mechanisms that when
we come to the table with an assumption
about greater reactivity, in one case,
diminish the reactivity. And another,
we need to be open to the possibility
that when we use multiple assessment
approaches,
we'll see fractionation so that
there'll be greater reactivity with some
measures and not with others.
Um,
I think on the regulation side we need
to be open to the possibility that the
simple starting point
of failed regulation,
they can't regulate needs to be unpacked.
And the reason that's so important
to draw these general lessons,
I think is that if we want
successful intervention strategies,
the more sophisticated we
can be about what's wrong,
the more likely we are to be able
to help people make it. Right.
Thank you. So it's been great
talking to you about, you know,
your thoughts on how we tease a part
emotion for emotion regulation. You know,
how we think about the future of emotion
and where it's headed and now linking
it to some clinical health outcomes.
And so all of that's been interesting.
And when you think now sort of more
broadly about the future of emotion,
where do you see the,
the sort of field headed?
I think that the larger fields we've
talked in this conversation about the many
exciting growth points as I see
them for emotion regulation.
Think as I've said,
there's room for theoretical advance here,
this room for empirical advances,
applications to clinical contexts
and uh, many other exciting, uh,
I think avenues for inquiry even in the
narrower domain of emotion regulation
and some of our work,
for example, we're, uh,
extending and this is where they run
help run in Israel looking at intractable
conflict and how emotion regulation
perspectives might actually make a
difference in these longstanding
intractable conflict.
So I think even moving beyond individual
level psychopathology and distressed
and much larger societal ills,
whether in intractable conflicts, uh,
or in the classroom,
uh,
I think there's lots of exciting work
to be done even in the narrower area of
emotion regulation.
I think if we broadened our view and
think very generally about the field of
emotion and even more
broadly to effect of science,
there's an incredible amount of exciting
opportunities for researchers and
students coming into the field today.
I think at play are basic questions
about how to conceptualize emotions,
whether they're things in the world that
were just describing or whether there
are things that are psychologically
constructed, um, uh, and therefore,
uh, you know, uh, amenable
to various interventions. Um,
I think we need to relate emotions however
there conceptualized to other effect
of processes like moods, all of this is
basic work that still needs to be done.
Um,
I think because we have new tools,
conceptual and empirical tools,
we're going to be,
I think a learning, an immense
amount about how emotions play out,
not just in the laboratory but in
the real world where they matter,
how they play out in social contexts,
how they play out over the course
of development. And I think there's,
in each of these subareas of psychology,
whatever one's starting point,
a very rich set of questions about the
nature of emotion and other affected
processes.
My particular focus of course is how they
can be modified and changed over time.
But I think that's just a tiny fraction
of the exciting sort of opportunities in
this larger space of effect of science.
So if you are talking to students,
you mentioned students, you know,
and sort of the future they
are going to be building in,
in learning about emotion
and emotion regulation,
what kind of advice would you have to
these students or people in general who
want to learn more about emotion,
where, where should they go?
Yeah, so I'm a, as you can hear,
very bullish about the future of
effect of science. I think if I were,
I'm happy to be in the field and if I
were advising students, I would say, Hey,
this great opportunity here.
Um,
they're just a very large
number of problems, uh, to,
to tackle that matter.
Um,
and I would recommend that they take a
good look at the field and the ways that
whatever their starting point,
they can link affected processes to their,
to their own interests.
Again,
whether it's developmental or clinical
or from a health psychology perspective,
lifespan, developmental, uh,
biological, cognitive, any of the,
uh, areas, uh, of the field, however
you define them, I think, uh,
are richly connected to these effective
processes. So I would say this is,
this is where a lot of actions going to
be happening over the next decade or two
in longer.
I would say please take a good
look at the field in terms of, uh,
how to get started.
I think the series that you're
building is a really exciting tool.
I think they're increasing opportunities
for students at different universities
in different contexts. Um, as I
tell my students, I, you know,
when I teach psychology one,
if they want to jump in and really
see what psychological science in this
spaces,
like they should join a research lab,
whether it's for a summer or whether it's
for a longer period of time to really
get involved in the sciences being done.
I think that's the way to really get a
feel beyond reading papers and end up in
books,
which is an obvious starting point.
Well, it sounds like it's an exciting
time for the future of emotion.
So I just want to thank you,
James for speaking with us today.
It's been a real pleasure.
My pleasure, Jane.
Thank you so much for the opportunity.
Yeah.
So this concludes our expert in emotion
interview with Dr. James Gross from
Stanford University.